I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate Office Lovers podcast just for you. Each week we will dive deeper into the world of the office with exclusive interviews behind the scenes details and lots of BFF stories. We're the Office Lady 6.0. Hi there, Angela. Well, hi there, Jenna.
我是珍娜·费舍尔，我是安吉拉·金西。我们一起出演过《办公室》，并且是最好的朋友。现在我们为你带来终极的《办公室》爱好者播客。每周，我们将通过独家采访、幕后细节和大量闺蜜故事，深入探讨《办公室》的世界。我们是办公室辣妈 6.0 版。你好啊，安吉拉。哦，你好啊，珍娜。
How are you doing? You know, I'm good. Is that it? Oh, you're just good. Now, is this one of those times when, like, you know when someone says, how are you doing? Yeah. And you're like, I can't get into it. And so you say, I'm good.
你最近怎么样？你知道的，我挺好的。就这样吗？哦，你就只是挺好。现在，这算不算是那种情况，就像，你知道当有人问“你最近怎么样？”时？对。然后你会想，我一言难尽，所以你就说，“我挺好的”。
Well, here's the thing. And I think you know this about me. I really have a hard time, like, just saying whatever the, like, normal responses. This is kind of true. Yeah. So, like, if people say, how are you? I might just say, well, you know, today, like everything feels a little shitty, but I'm out there. I'm living. I'm putting one foot in front of
好吧，情况是这样的。我想你对我这点很了解。我真的很难随口说出那种，比如，很正常的回答。这倒挺真的。所以，如果人们问，你最近怎么样？我可能就会说，嗯，你知道的，今天感觉所有事情都有点操蛋，但我还在坚持。我还在生活。我正在过好每一天。
the other. And then if you say that, though, people are like, uh, okay. But lady, this is why I love you. This is very Midwest of you. I notice this every time I go home to St. Louis, like, I go to the grocery store line and I'm checking out or something. And the person says, how are you? And I say, fine. I give the Los Angeles response. Yeah. And I say, how about you? And then they say something, like deeply personal. Yeah.
然后如果你这么说了，人们就会觉得，呃，好吧。但亲爱的，这就是我爱你的原因。你这非常有中西部风格。每次我回圣路易斯老家时都会注意到这一点，比如我去杂货店排队结账什么的。然后那个人问，你最近怎么样？我说，挺好。我给出了洛杉矶式的回答。对。然后我说，你呢？接着他们就会说出一些，比如极其私人的事情。对。
They're like, well, my sister was arrested last night. I'm like, oh, she what? And they're like, yep, I mean, she's been in trouble before. But I don't know. It's okay. I think we've got a lawyer. And I'm like, oh, my gosh. I mean, it happens all the time.
他们会说，哦，我姐姐昨晚被捕了。我就想，哦，她怎么了？他们会说，对啊，我是说，她以前就惹过麻烦。不过，我不知道。没关系。我想我们已经找了律师。我就想，哦，天哪。我的意思是，这种事经常发生。
And so I think that's how you remind me of home. I love it. I don't mind it at all. It is true because my family does this. Like, I'll be like, you know, how's it going? They're like, well, the cattle guard's not getting fixed because, you know, Tommy went blind again. He's got that plate in his head, moves around every once in a while. Yeah.
所以我想这就是你让我怀念家乡的地方。我很喜欢。我一点也不介意。确实如此，因为我家人就会这样。比如我会问，最近怎么样？他们会说，噢，牛栏没修好，因为，你知道的，汤米又瞎了。他脑子里有块钢板，每隔一段时间就会移位。对。
That's a real statement my mom said to me. Yeah, I know. Yeah. I like it. All right. Makes you more interesting personally. Although I have been in your position and I have received blank stairs from people when I share in the same way. Like, it just happened at a school event.
那是我妈妈对我说过的话。对，我知道。对。我喜欢。好吧。这让你个人更有意思。虽然我也经历过你的处境，当我以同样的方式分享时，我从别人那里收到过空白的眼神。比如，这刚刚在学校活动上发生过。
Someone asked me how I was. And I just, honestly, I didn't get a lot of sleep last night. It's not always a complaint either. It's true. It's true. It's true. But it sounds like it's always a gripe, but it's not. I will.
有人问我最近怎么样。我只是，说实话，我昨晚没睡好。这倒也不一定总是在抱怨。是真的。是真的。是真的。但听起来总像是在发牢骚，其实并不是。我会。
Like, someone like, how's it going? Great. I just found a pair of jeans. I thought I had lost for a long time. And they're like, really my favorite. They're like a lucky brand. They don't make them anymore. You know, like the low-wasted ones.
比如有人问，最近怎么样？太棒了。我刚找到了一条以为已经丢了很久的牛仔裤。他们就会问，真的吗，我最喜欢的？就像那种幸运品牌的牛仔裤。他们现在不生产了。你知道的，就像那种低腰的裤子。
Everything's now is like up at your belly button. Who needs that crap? And I might say that. I know. But isn't that interesting. That makes for an interesting moment in a day. If you answer a question with like weird specificity. Or it clears the room.
现在所有裤子都提到肚脐眼那儿了。谁需要那种垃圾？我可能会这么说。我知道。但这不是很有趣吗？在日常生活中，如果用一种奇怪的具体方式回答问题，就会造就有趣的时刻。或者直接把场面弄得鸦雀无声。
It does. Okay. What should we do? Oh, we should do our chit-chat suggestion. Now it felt like a lot of chit-chat. Let's do it. This one is coming in from Nat S in Baldwin, Missouri. That's my hometown.
确实。好吧，我们该做什么？哦，我们该做闲聊建议了。现在感觉有好多闲聊。我们开始吧。这条留言来自密苏里州鲍德温的娜特·S。那是我的家乡。
Literally, Ballwin, Missouri is my hometown. You're kidding. Ballwin? Yeah, it's a suburb of St. Louis. Okay. All right, let's listen. Hi, ladies. This is Nat from Missouri. If you had unlimited creative freedom and an endless budget, tell us all about the story you'd want to produce, either together or separately. It could be a movie or a TV show, chat about potential casting and plot lines, or maybe even chat about what kinds of stories you wish you saw more of in today's world. Thanks for picking my question. You ladies are so groovy. Love you lots and keep it up. I mean, that's a big question. Nat? Nat? I'm going to say there are so many stories I would love to bring to life, so many parts I would love to play myself. And I don't think it's a matter of endless creative freedom or endless budget, although that would help. For me, it would be, I need endless bandwidth and time.
真的，密苏里州鲍德温就是我的家乡。你在开玩笑吧？鲍德温？对，它是圣路易斯的一个郊区。好吧。好的，我们来听听。嗨，女士们，我是来自密苏里州的娜特。如果你有无限的创作自由和无尽的预算，请跟我们讲讲你想制作的故事，无论是合作还是各自制作。可以是一部电影或一部电视剧，聊聊潜在的选角和剧情，或者甚至聊聊你希望在当今世界看到更多什么样的故事。谢谢你选中我的问题。女士们，你们太棒了。爱你们哟，加油。我的天，这可真是个大问题。娜特？娜特？我想说，有太多故事我想将它们搬上银幕，有太多角色我想亲自出演。我觉得这并不是有没有无限创作自由或无限预算的问题，尽管那确实有帮助。对我来说，我需要的是无尽的精力和时间。
I feel like, or to clone myself, I feel like there's so many things. I mean, the first one coming to mind is mom detectives, which I can't do because I just, don't have the time to bring that into the world. The way we would want to do it. Yeah. Yeah. I mean, I agree. I mean, I do love this question because it let me daydream a little.
我觉得，或者克隆我自己，我觉得有太多事情了。我的意思是，脑海中浮现的第一个就是“妈妈侦探”，我做不到是因为我根本没有时间把这个创意带到这个世界上。以我们想要的方式去做。对。对。我的意思是，我同意。我是说，我真的很喜欢这个问题，因为它让我稍微做了一下白日梦。
Like, Nat, for one, there's a lot of great stories that haven't been told about women who were cowgirls, like real working cowgirls. And there's some great stories. And I've read a few, and I'm like, gosh, that would make an amazing movie. Just highlight one of them that rode horseback and worked. the land just like hardcore. I would love that movie. Like that would be something I would want to see. Yeah. So that's a story I always thought would be cool to tell like the women of the West, you know? Yes. And then for me also mom detectives. And I'll tell you why. Jen and I,
比如，娜特，首先，有很多极棒的故事还没有被讲述，关于那些曾经是女牛仔的女性，真正的职业女牛仔。有一些非常棒的故事。我读过几个，当时就想，天哪，这会拍成一部惊艳的电影。只要突出其中一个骑马并在恶劣环境中辛勤劳动的女性就行。我太想看那部电影了。就像那会是我想要看的东西。对。所以这是一个我一直觉得很酷的故事，比如讲述西部的女性，你知道的？是的。然后对我来说，还有“妈妈侦探”。我来告诉你为什么，珍娜和我，
like, we don't do anything half ass. If we were to do this, we would do it and we don't have time to do it. But I even fantasize about the cast because that's where I have the most fun when I think about projects is like seeing who I would want. So Nat and Jenna, this is my daydream cast for mom detectives. Oh, I can't wait to hear it. Okay. Husbands, Steve Little, and Tone Bell. Amazing. Amazing. Neighbors that we drive crazy with our mom detectiveness. Bobby Lee. Mm-hmm. Rachel Dratch, Timberley Hill, who's hilarious. Then I also want the two guys across the street that hosts the 4th of July barbecue every year. year. This is also in my neighborhood. They're very serious about their meat. You're going to have to go over there. It's like a big deal. Okay. They're very intense. I want local cops that we butt heads with
我们做事从来不会敷衍了事。如果要拍这个，我们就会全力以赴，但我们没有时间去做。不过我甚至连演员阵容都幻想好了，因为这正是我构思项目时最开心的地方，就像看看我会想要谁。所以，娜特和珍娜，这是我心目中“妈妈侦探”的梦幻演员阵容。哦，我等不及想听了。好的。丈夫，史蒂夫·利特尔和托恩·贝尔。太棒了。太棒了。被我们的妈妈侦探气到发狂的邻居。鲍比·李。嗯哼。雷切尔·德拉奇，蒂姆伯利·希尔，她太搞笑了。然后我还想要街对面的那两个家伙，他们每年都举办独立日烧烤派对。这也是我邻居。他们对自己的肉非常认真。你得过去一趟。这像是一件大事。好吧。他们非常狂热。我想要跟我们针锋相对的当地警察
because we're mom detectives. I want them to be Jim Gaffigan and Jason Antoon. Okay. I mean, I just think that would be a blast. That would be such a blast. Yeah. Yeah. Can't you just see us like getting in a scuttlebutt with Jim Gaff again? And Jason Antoon was in a pilot I did. called the 46 percenters. He's in NCIS, Hawaii. He's so funny. And Steve Little, my God, tone bell, we did bad judge together with Kate Walsh. And I couldn't even make eye contact with him for half his lines because I would just bust up. I want us to have a revolving door of directors we love, like Denny Gordon, Ken Quappas, Paul Figue. Yeah. See, we need the endless bandwidth. We do. And we do need funds because that's a big cast.
因为我们是妈妈侦探。我希望他们是吉姆·加菲根和杰森·安东。好吧。我的意思是，我只是觉得那会太有趣了。那会太有趣了。对。对。你难道不能想象我们和吉姆·加菲根斗嘴的场景吗？而且杰森·安东演过我的一部试播集，叫《46%的人》。他在《海军罪案调查处：夏威夷》里。他太搞笑了。还有史蒂夫·利特尔，天哪，托恩·贝尔，我们和凯特·沃尔什一起拍过《不良法官》。他有一半的台词我甚至都不敢和他对视，因为我会直接笑场。我希望我们有一批我们热爱的导演轮流执导，比如丹尼·戈登、肯·夸帕斯、保罗·费格。对。你看，我们需要无尽的精力。确实需要。而且我们确实需要资金，因为演员阵容太庞大了。
It is. Well, I have also always wanted to do a biopic on Ruth Fertle. She's the founder of Ruth's Chris Steakhouse. Oh, yeah, you love her. You've talked about her on here before. I did. I gave a whole deep dive on her badassery and how she put her name on that steakhouse. And I think it would make an amazing movie. And I think that Julia Garner should play her. This would be my dream casting. I love her. I just. I saw her in weapons, and there's this scene and weapons in the bar, and she's just so good. I would love to also work with Julia Garner. You know another thing that I would really like? What? If we're just putting out. Sure. I wish I could go back and have all the shows that I've developed and pitched get made.
确实。嗯，我一直还想拍一部关于露丝·费特尔的传记片。她是露丝克里斯牛排馆的创始人。哦，对，你很喜欢她。你以前在这里谈论过她。我确实谈过。我深入探讨了她的女汉子作风，以及她是如何将自己的名字印在那家牛排馆上的。我觉得这会拍成一部极棒的电影。而且我认为朱莉娅·加纳应该扮演她。这就是我的梦幻选角。我太喜欢她了。我只是。我在《武器》里看过她，里面有一场在酒吧的戏，她演得太棒了。我也很想和朱莉娅·加纳合作。你知道我还真的很想要什么吗？什么？如果我们只是在许愿的话。当然。我希望我能回到过去，把我开发和推销过的所有剧集都拍出来。
Like, there was this one I did called National Parker. It was written by my friend Alex Henriksen and Corinne Marshall. It was so funny. It was about like a kind of like socialized. woman, young woman from New York who decides to give up everything and become a park ranger. She's having just sort of like a midlife crisis at 22, basically. She's like, who am I? What am I? And then imagine like a young Goldie Hawn type. Yeah. And then she goes into the forest with all of these park rangers. And it was so funny. And we developed it for so long.
比如，我以前做过一个叫《国家帕克》的项目。它是我的朋友亚历克斯·亨里克森和科琳·马歇尔写的。太逗了。讲的是一个来自纽约的、有点像社交名媛的年轻女性，她决定放弃一切去当一名公园管理员。她基本上是在22岁时经历了一场中年危机。她就像是在想，我是谁？我到底是什么？然后想象一下，就像是一个年轻的歌蒂·韩那种类型。对。接着她和这群公园管理员一起深入森林。真的太搞笑了。我们为这个项目筹备了很久。
It was bought. It was developed. We wrote a pilot. It didn't get picked up. And I just, I would love to see those out in the world. There's so many. Yeah, I would love that too. I would love the pilot that I developed and sold and wrote for TBS Holiday. Yes. About my hometown of Archer City. I read it. It's so funny. And what about she bangs? Oh, she bangs. Oh, you guys, we have the funniest movie script that Jenna's husband Lee wrote. We did the story. We did the story. We would sit down at your kitchen table. It was so fun. We were laughing so hard. We were laughing so hard. we were crying, like just kind of like brainstorming scenes and these characters, and Lee would just be taking notes. And then he wrote the funniest script. I know. There's so many things.
项目被买下来了。也进行了开发。我们写了一个试播集。但没有被预订。我真的、真的很想让这些作品跟观众见面。有好多呢。对，我也很想。我还想看到我为TBS假日开发、出售并编写的试播集。没错。关于我的家乡阿彻城。我看过那个剧本。太搞笑了。那《她大喊大叫》呢？哦，《她大喊大叫》！哦，天哪，我们有一个超搞笑的电影剧本，是珍娜的丈夫李写的。我们一起构思了故事。我们一起构思了故事。我们会围坐在你家的厨房桌子旁。太有趣了。我们笑得前俯后仰。我们笑得眼泪都快出来了，就像是一起头脑风暴各种场景和角色，而李就在一旁做笔记。然后他写出了最搞笑的剧本。我懂。真的有太多东西了。
But to develop something like that, it's so much sweat equity. Yeah. You don't get paid for it. It's a full-time job. It's a full-time job. And we have a full-time job, which is this podcast. And also when you get immersed in that sort of thing, it really takes away from your family. And I want to be really present to my family. So that's a full-time job. So that's a lot. That's why I don't do all the extras. I can do like one extra project a year and still have the home life I want. Yeah. We can do little mini things right now. And they're so creatively fulfilling. And I'm so thankful for them. But gosh, it's hard to beat the amazing creative freedom we have right here. Yeah. I love it. I do, too. Well, Nat, thank you.
但是要开发这样的项目，需要付出太多的心血和劳动。是的。而且你是拿不到报酬的。这是一份全职工作。这绝对是一份全职工作。我们已经有一份全职工作了，那就是这个播客。而且当你全身心投入到那种事情中时，真的会无暇顾及家人。我希望能够真正多陪陪我的家人。所以这也是一份全职工作。真的有够受的。这就是为什么我不会去接所有额外的工作。我一年只能做一个额外的项目，同时还能保持我想要的家庭生活。是的。我们现在可以做一些小短片。它们在创意上同样令人满足。我对此非常感激。不过天哪，要想超越我们现在拥有的这种惊人的创作自由，还真是不容易。是的。我喜欢这样。我也是。好吧，娜特，谢谢你。
Yeah. I think if we had to pick, we'd want to do something we can do together. Like she bangs or mom to objectives. Unlimited money, unlimited creative freedom, and unlimited bandwidth. And then maybe if we had all the bandwidth in the world, we'd produce all these other kick-ass things that we're not even in. Exactly. All right. Well, listen, why don't we take a break? And then when we come back, we are going to break down season one, episode four of the paper. All right. Hi, this is Jill Schlesinger, CBS News, Business Analyst, Certified Financial Planner, and the host of the Jill on Money podcast. With a new year upon us, there's no better. time to take control of your financial life and the Jill on Money podcast is here to help.
是的。我想如果我们必须做出选择，我们会想做一些我们可以一起完成的事情。比如《她大喊大叫》或者针对妈妈的项目。有无限的金钱、无限的创作自由，还有无限的精力。然后也许如果我们拥有全世界所有的精力，我们会制作所有这些其他超酷的东西，虽然我们甚至不会在里面出镜。没错。好了，听着，我们为什么不休息一下呢？等我们回来，我们将剖析《The Paper》第一季第四集。好的。嗨，我是吉尔·施莱辛格，CBS新闻商业分析师、注册理财规划师，同时也是《吉尔谈理财》播客的主持人。随着新年的到来，现在正是掌控你财务生活的最佳时机，《吉尔谈理财》播客将为你提供帮助。
It's your questions that make it possible for me to provide unconventional and I hope entertaining insights on your money, more importantly, on your life. Follow and listen to Jill on Money wherever you get your podcasts. We are back. We're talking today about episode four TTT versus the blogger. Yeah. And it's a really fun episode. I do want to say one thing before we do.
正是你们的提问，让我能够对你们的财务状况，更重要的是对你们的生活，提供不落俗套且希望颇具娱乐性的见解。无论你在哪里收听播客，都可以关注并收听《吉尔谈理财》。我们回来啦。我们今天要讨论的是第四集《TTT对决博主》。是的。这一集真的非常有趣。在深入探讨之前，我确实想说一件事。
dig in, which is, guys, we have not forgot about around the town. Yes, around the town. We're so excited. You have written in some great stuff, and I can't wait for us to share it. We just need a minute. We're having some transitions and we just need a minute. Yes, we're transitioning between our producers. It's the new year, but we have a goal that we're going to have around the town in the next
那就是，大家，我们没有忘记“走遍小镇”这个环节。是的，“走遍小镇”。我们太兴奋了。你们写来了很多棒极了的内容，我等不及要和大家分享了。我们只是需要一点时间。我们正在经历一些人员交接，所以我们只需要一点时间。是的，我们在不同的制作人之间做交接。现在是新年，但我们有一个目标，要在下一集中推出“走遍小镇”。
episode. Yeah, but they're fantastic, and I can't thank you enough. All right. This episode was written by Amanda Rosenberg and directed by, Paul Lieberstein. Yes, it was. Here is your summary. A visit from high school journalism students Stokes competition between Ned, Esmeralda, and a local high school news blogger. Mayor and Oscar investigate a retiring music teacher with a questionable past. Meanwhile, Detrick comes on too strong with Nicole. I mean, he whittled a bird. He sure did. I did go down a rabbit hole of watching
是的，但这些内容真的很棒，我对你们感激不尽。好了。这一集由阿曼达·罗森伯格编剧，保罗·利伯斯坦执导。没错，确实如此。以下是本集剧情梗概：高中新闻系学生的造访引发了内德、埃斯梅拉达和当地一名高中新闻博主之间的竞争。市长和奥斯卡调查了一位有着可疑过去的退休音乐老师。与此同时，迪特里克对妮可表现得过于热情。我是说，他削了一只鸟。他确实削了。我的确在YouTube上深入研究了别人用木头做鸟的视频。你还真看了。当我们聊到这里时，你能给我们分享一些细节吗？我唯一想让你知道的细节就是我被迷住了。就这样。大家都有很多了不起的技能，而且他们都在乐于分享。好吧。让我们进入这一集。
people make birds out of wood on YouTube. You did. Will you give us some details when we get to it? The only detail I want you to know is that I became fascinated. That's it. People have a lot of amazing skills out there, and they're sharing them. Okay. Let's get to this episode.
好了。这一集从新闻编辑室开始，有一群来自代里斯堡高中的高中新闻系学生，他们将来到“真话者”办公室进行观摩。是的。一个真正运转中的报纸。他们开始询问关于新闻业务的问题。哦，天哪，我觉得这太搞笑了。而且我觉得特拉维斯表现得非常具有特拉维斯特色。我甚至截取了一段音频。哦。因为其中两个高中生一开场就语出惊人。我太喜欢特拉维斯的反应了。我只想让你们听一听这个开场白的一小段。大家热烈欢迎代里斯堡高中的同学们。新闻业的未来，见识一下
All right. This episode opens in the bullpen with a group of high school journalism students from Daryesburg High, and they are going to come into the Truth Teller offices to observe. Yeah. A real working newspaper. They start asking questions about journalistic practices. Oh, lady, I thought this was so funny. And I thought Travis was being classic Travis. I actually pulled a clip. Oh. Because two of the high schoolers throw shade right out of the gate. I love Travis's reaction. I just want you to hear a snippet of this cold open. Everyone give a warm welcome to the students of Derrysburg High School. Future of journalism, meet
新闻业的现在。你们可以问他们任何想问的问题。别害羞，伙计们。你们不需要对我们感到畏惧。我们是来帮你们的，好吗？没有哪个问题是太愚蠢的。你们认为对匿名消息来源的过度依赖会损害公众信任吗？这真是一个绝妙的问题，而且非常耐人寻味。
Present of journalism. You can ask them anything you want. Don't be shy, guys. You do not need to be intimidated by us. We are here to help you, all right? No question is too stupid. Do you think an over-reliance on anonymous sources damages public trust? That's an amazing question, and it's very curious.
谁想回答这个问题？我觉得我快把对话全占了。这把我逗乐了，因为这是我最喜欢做的事情之一。比如，如果我和一个我很熟悉的人在一起，比如乔伊、你或者别的什么人，而我们处在某种派对氛围中。然后我被问到某个问题，但我其实没有一个很好的答案，我就会说：“你知道吗，乔伊，我觉得你应该来回答，因为你对此有很多想法。”哦，这不就像是喜剧演员之间经常开的那个玩笑吗？就是你把某人架起来，对他说：“哦天哪，他有一个超级搞笑的故事。”
Who wants to take this one? I feel like I'm monopolizing the conversation. Cracked me up because it's one of my favorite things to do. Like, if I'm with someone I know really well, like Josh or you or whatever, and we're in like some kind of like party atmosphere. And I get like asked something and I don't really have a great answer. I'm like, you know what, Josh, I think you should go because you have so many thoughts on this. Well, isn't that like that's such a joke between comedians where you like set someone up by saying like, oh my gosh, they have the funniest story.
你来讲吧。结果让人感觉很难不负众望。但我太喜欢了。特拉维斯就用了那种经典的“把球踢给别人”的招数。接着我们发现，这些学生为学校校报撰写文章的经验，竟然比TTT的记者还要丰富。是的。我得谈谈这一幕里的服装。哦，好吧。我真的特别关注了这个。
Take it away. And it's just like so hard to live up to that. But I loved it. Travis did that classic, pass the book. And then we go on to find out that the students have more experience writing articles for their school newspaper than the journalists at TTT. Yes. I need to talk about the wardrobe in this scene. Oh, okay. I really zeroed in on it.
好吧。你们有没有注意到，学生们和记者们的穿着打扮基本上是一样的？除了迪特里克，他穿着西装外套打着领带。内德系了领带，但他还穿着一件类似麂皮夹克的外套，不过其他所有人的穿着都非常休闲。我觉得这真的很有意思。而且，没有一个女性在穿裙子。哦，一条都没有。时代变了。还记得你、我、菲利斯、凯特、明迪，我们以前都必须穿裙子。我们的连衣裙，是的。在每一集里，你都找不到一条裙子。
Okay. Did you notice how the students and the reporters were all dressed basically the same? With the exception of Detrick, who is in a, like a suit coat and a tie. and Ned has on a tie, but he also has on like a suede jacket, but everyone is dressed really casually. And I thought that was really interesting. Also, none of the women are wearing skirts. Oh, none. Times have changed. Remember how you, me, Phyllis, Kate, Mindy, we all had to wear skirts. Our dresses, yeah. In every episode, there was not a skirt to be found.
还有，你们注意到市长的开衫了吗？那是一件宽松的条纹开衫。真的非常有弗莱迪·克鲁格的感觉。是吗？我倒没觉得像弗莱迪·克鲁格。在我看来非常像弗莱迪·克鲁格。好吧。不过我可不是唯一一个注意到市长开衫的人。哦。
Also, did you notice Mayer's cardigan? It was this slouchy striped cardigan. It was really giving like Freddie Kruger vibes. Was it? I didn't think of Freddie Krueger. It looked very Freddie Kruger to me. Okay. But I'm not the only person who notices Marr's cardigans. Oh.
我们收到了波特兰的娜塔莉·M发来的一封信，她说：“在很多集里，我总觉得市长让我想起了某个人，然后我突然想到了。科特·柯本。”不是吧。市长看起来就像个科特·柯本的模仿者，那个发型、宽松的开衫、T恤、厚底鞋、混搭的图案，难道只有我一个人这么觉得吗？你们做过对比图吗？你知道我做了，天哪。
We got a letter from Natalie M. in Portland who said, for many of the episodes, I would always think that Mayor reminded me of someone and then it hit me. Kurt Cobain. No. Mayor looks like a Kurt Cobain impersonator with the hair, the slouchy cardigans, the t-shirts, the dull-toe. the mix-match patterns, is this only me? Did you do a side-by-side? You know I did, lady.
你知道我不会放过任何做对比图的机会。你发给切尔西了吗？没有，我应该发给她的。给你看。哦，天哪。太绝了。真的挺棒的。娜塔莉，你百分之百猜对了。
You know I love any chance for a side-by-side. Did you send it to Chelsea? No, I should. Here it is. Oh, my God. It's amazing. That's pretty great. Natalie, you are 100% correct.
我懂那种氛围。我懂的。对吧？顺便说一句，这张对比照里科特·柯本穿的那件宽松毛衣非常有名。它被认为是音乐史上最著名的毛衣之一，在拍卖会上拍出了33.4万美元的高价。哦，哇。是的。你可以把这个放进动态里，亲爱的。我会把你们的对比图发到动态里的。太棒了。我的对比图登上动态啦。是的。
I see the vibe. I see it. Right? Yeah. Incidentally, the slouchy sweater that Kurt Cobain is wearing in this side-by-side picture is very famous. It is considered one of the most famous sweaters in music history, and it sold at auction for $334,000. Oh, wow. Yeah. You can put that in stories, lady. I will put your side-by-side. Yay. My side-by-side made the stories. Yeah.
test
That's sort of like, is that like the also news, or is it? The stories is the also news. I didn't make the feed. Instagram stories. I like our stories. Me too. I think they're better than the also news. I aspire to one day make the feed. The feed.
有点像是，那也是新闻，还是说？报道才是“也算新闻”。又不是我排的版。Instagram 快拍。我挺喜欢我们的快拍。我也是。我觉得它们比“也算新闻”更好。我渴望有一天能登上头版。头版。
All right. Where are we? Oh, it's opening credits. Yep. Ned is meeting with one student in particular, and she asks him, what does it cost to run the truth teller every year? And Ned sort of flippantly says, I don't know, the monthly budget is about half a million dollars. And the student's like, whoa. And he's like, pretty cool, right?
好吧。我们讲到哪了？哦，是片头。没错。内德正在跟一个学生单独谈话，她问他，每年运营“实话实说报”要花多少钱？内德有点轻率地回答，我不知道，每月的预算大约是五十万美元。那个学生一脸“哇塞”。然后他说，挺酷的对吧？
And she says, how do you expect you can survive with so much waste? Yeah. Well, this did get me curious. About what? I mean, how much money does it cost to put a newspaper out? And there's a website that you and Dr. Tibido would love. It's called macro trends. And they run all this data.
她说，你怎么指望这么大的浪费还能存活下去？好吧。这确实让我很好奇。好奇什么？我是说，出一份报纸到底要花多少钱？有个网站你和蒂比多博士一定会喜欢。它叫宏观趋势网（Macrotrends）。他们处理所有这些数据。
And according to them, the New York Times, for example, their operating expenses for the 12 months ending September 30th, 2025 were about $2.3 billion. To put out the New York Times for a year? Yeah. Wow. Yeah. I mean, they have a lot of reporters and really obscure places around the globe. Yeah. Whereas the truth teller does not. Those people who have never written articles. Well, the student that Ned's talking to, Davy, asked him, does he feel threatened by TTT's real competition, which is a high school-run blog called So Wesley. We learn it's by a student named Wesley, and it's the most popular blog in Lucas County with 300,000 subscribers. Yeah, he's like, did you say 300 or 3,000? And she's like, 300,000. I've got a guest star breakdown for you on
据他们所说，以《纽约时报》为例，截至2025年9月30日的12个月里，他们的运营费用大约是23亿美元。运营《纽约时报》一年就要这么多？是啊。哇。对啊。我是说，他们在全球很多偏僻的地方都有大量记者。没错。而“实话实说报”则没有。那些从未写过文章的人。嗯，内德正在交谈的学生黛维问他，他是否觉得来自“实话实说报”真正竞争对手的威胁，那是一个由高中运营的博客，名叫“索韦斯利”。我们得知这是由一个叫韦斯利的学生创办的，它是卢卡斯县最受欢迎的博客，拥有30万订阅者。对，他当时说，你是说300还是3000？然后她说，30万。我这里有一份客串演员的介绍，关于
Davy. Okay. It's Julia Butters, and she's actually 16 years old. She was on the show American Housewife, and she was also in Quentin Tarantino's movie Once Upon a Time in Hollywood. Lady. Yeah. Did you see Zach Woods' takedown of Quentin Tarantino last year? Did you see it? I did. Go just to the comments.
黛维。好的。她是茱莉亚·巴特斯，她今年其实16岁。她出演过电视剧《美国家庭主妇》，她还参演了昆汀·塔伦蒂诺的电影《好莱坞往事》。天哪。对啊。你去年看到扎克·伍兹痛斥昆汀·塔伦蒂诺了吗？你看了吗？我看了。去看评论区吧。
The comments are amazing. You know what happened is that for whatever reason, Quentin Tarantino decided to go off on like Paul Dano in an interview. And Paul Dano's just living his life? Paul Dano's like, what the fuck did I do? the hell just happened? Why am I in this conversation? And so Zach Woods decided to come to the defense of Paul Dano in like a hilarious, hilarious monologue on his Instagram. Zach Wood's Instagram is so funny. Because he's so smart. He's so, his brain is so fast.
评论区太精彩了。你知道发生了什么吗，不知为什么，昆汀·塔伦蒂诺在一次采访中突然开始长篇大论地数落保罗·达诺。而保罗·达诺当时只是在过他自己的日子？保罗·达诺心想，我他妈做错了什么？到底发生了什么鬼？为什么我会被卷进这个话题里？于是扎克·伍兹决定在Instagram上发表一段极其搞笑的独白，来为保罗·达诺辩护。扎克·伍兹的Instagram太搞笑了。因为他太聪明了。他的脑子转得太快了。
Yeah. And he can do a thing like that that is hilarious, but also scathing. Yes. We need him on Office Ladies Burn It to the Ground. Oh. We need him. He needs to sit in the room for the whole thing. Yes, 100%. And just do commentary. Yes. Well, Mayor is now talking to the students, and she finds out that the high school music teacher, Mr. Kay, a very long-time, beloved teacher, is retiring. He's directing one last show. It's a gender-swapped production of mean girls titled Mean Boys. Yeah. And Mayor definitely gets a look across her face when Mr. Kay's name is brought up. And she's like, oh, yeah, I remember him. I remember all my teachers. But, you know, something's laying underneath the surface there. So, Mayor asks if she and Oscar can go to the high school.
对。而且他能做出那种既搞笑又刻薄的事。是的。我们需要他来“办公室辣妈：把这烧成平地”节目。哦。我们需要他。他得全程坐在录音室里。是的，百分之百。只负责做解说。没错。好了，梅尔现在正在跟学生们谈话，她发现学校的音乐老师凯老师，一位深受爱戴的资深老师，要退休了。他正在导演最后一场演出。这是一部由女孩反串男角的《贱女孩》，剧名叫《贱男孩》。是的。当提到凯老师的名字时，梅尔的脸上确实闪过了一种神情。她就说，哦，对，我记得他。我记得我所有的老师。但是，你知道的，这其中有什么东西潜藏在水面之下。所以，梅尔问她和奥斯卡能不能去高中。
Mayor's going to write a feature on Mr. Kay, and Oscar is going to review the play. Ned says that sounds great. Ned is a tad distracted, though. He's pretty rattled by this So Wesley guy. He is. And he goes online and looks him up. And he starts reading one of, Wesley's articles, and he thinks he's found an error. Wesley has used inflammable when Ned thinks he should have said flammable, right? Yeah. So he leaves a snarky comment. He writes, Ever heard of proofreading? Maybe you should have been in the journalism class at the truth teller this morning, a winky face. Lady, would you leave a comment? Well, I like to read comments. It's very hard for me sometimes to leave a comment. I like to have a more. I like to have a more.
梅尔打算写一篇关于凯老师的专题报道，而奥斯卡则要去观看并评论这部戏剧。内德说听起来不错。不过内德有点走神。他被这个叫“索韦斯利”家伙搞得心神不宁。确实如此。他上网查了查对方。然后他开始阅读韦斯利的一篇文章，他觉得他发现了一个错误。韦斯利用了“不燃的（inflammable）”，而内德认为他应该用“易燃的（flammable）”，对吧？没错。于是他留下了一条尖酸刻薄的评论。他写道，听说过校对吗？也许你今天早上真该去“实话实说报”上个新闻课，加一个眨眼的表情。天哪，你会留评论吗？嗯，我喜欢看评论。有时我要留评论对我来说挺难的。我喜欢保持一种更。我喜欢保持一种更。
more observational relationship with the news and with social media. Sometimes I know I should comment and I have to kind of like make myself leave a comment. Well, you are half of America. Half of us don't leave comments. But like for a friend's birthday, I should comment. And so I'll comment. But other than that, you're not going to hear from me in the comments. I think it's okay.
更具观察视角的、与新闻以及社交媒体的关系。有时我知道我应该评论，而且我得逼着自己去留个评论。好吧，你代表了半个美国。我们有一半人是不留评论的。不过比如为了朋友生日，我应该评论。所以我会评论。但除此之外，你在评论区是不会听到我的声音的。我觉得这挺正常的。
Okay, good. Well, you are going to hear from Ned, and that's going to blow up. Yes. All of a sudden, Ned is in his office, and he overhears Esmeralda laughing. He goes over to her office to see what's going on. Guess what? So Wesley has written a blog about Ned's comment. So Wesley says, in a pathetic attempt to clawback relevancy,
好吧，那就好。不过，你肯定会听到内德的声音，而且那要炸锅了。是的。突然之间，内德在他的办公室里，无意中听到埃斯梅拉达在大笑。他走到她的办公室去看发生了什么事。你猜怎么着？“索韦斯利”写了一篇关于内德评论的博客。“索韦斯利”写道，在一场可悲的试图挽回 relevance 的尝试中，
Ned Sampson, editor-in-chief and supposed grown man, decided to verbally assault me in the comments of this blog. But what's worse is he used this emoji? And then he has the winky face. Ken enters and he says, you have to apologize. You have to apologize. He has a lot of influence around town. More than you, Ned. And Ned is like, I'm not going to do it. I'm not going to apologize. One thing we need to mention, too, that we didn't mention a minute ago is that there is an Oscar talking head where Oscar lets the documentary crew, know that he is going to the high school for his article not to be part of the documentary. Yes. He's still not interested in being part of the documentary. So don't think that's happening.
内德·桑普森，总编辑兼所谓的大老爷们，决定在这个博客的评论区对我进行言语攻击。但更糟糕的是，他用了这个表情符号？然后他就用了那个眨眼的表情。肯进来了，他说，你得道歉。你必须道歉。他在镇上有很大的影响力。比你大，内德。而内德却说，我才不干。我才不道歉。还有一件事我们需要提一下，刚才我们漏掉了，那就是有一个奥斯卡的个人独白镜头，奥斯卡让纪录片摄制组知道，他去高中是为了他的文章，而不是为了成为纪录片的一部分。是的。他对参与纪录片依然不感兴趣。所以别指望那会发生。
Make no mistake. Yeah. He will only speak to the documentary crew if it is about the newspaper and like his newspaper job. Which is, he says he's just here to promote art and leisure. That's it. It's very finer things club of him. And very much so is. I need to talk about Esmeralda's desk for a second. And I know you did a big breakdown of her desk in the first episode, but I don't believe that these two items were on her desk in the first episode. Correct me if I'm wrong, but they're very prominent in this episode. She has two mirrors facing her. Yes. Have they always been there?
别搞错了。对。他只会在跟报纸以及他的报纸工作有关的情况下，才会跟纪录片摄制组讲话。也就是，他说他来这里只是为了推广艺术与休闲。就这样。这非常符合他的“精致生活俱乐部”作风。确实非常符合。我得花一秒钟讨论一下埃斯梅拉达的桌子。我知道你在第一集中对她的桌子做过详细盘点，但我相信这两样东西在第一集里不在她的桌上。如果我错了请纠正我，但它们在这集里非常显眼。她有两个朝向她自己的镜子。是的。它们一直都在那儿吗？
And I just noticed them. Yeah. She's had the mirrors and all the lamps and all the stars. Yes. Okay. So when she's sitting at her desk, she has two mirrors. and she can look at herself, I would never. They're also kind of like at a low angle.
而我刚刚才注意到。对。她一直都有那些镜子，还有所有的台灯和所有的星星。是的。所以当她坐在桌子前时，她有两面镜子。她可以看着自己，我才不要那样。它们角度还挺低的。
That is, I do not want to see that all day long. I told you about that house we rented for Josh's mom's 70th birthday. No. Why? Oh, my gosh. Okay, so it's her 70th birthday, and we all decide we're going to meet up somewhere warm because, you know, they had this cold winter in Colorado, and we're going to go somewhere warm for her birthday.
那就是，我可不想一整天都看到那个。我跟你说过我们为乔什妈妈70岁生日租的那栋房子吗？没有。为什么？哦，天哪。好吧，那是她的70岁生日，我们大家决定在某个温暖的地方碰头，因为，你知道的，科罗拉多那边的冬天太冷了，我们要去一个温暖的地方给她过生日。
So we rent this house. for the whole family. We all chip in, and we rent this big house in Palm Springs. And we divide up the bedrooms. And Josh and I ended up getting this bedroom of this house. And we walk in it and we're like, oh, such a nice room. And then Josh, he goes in the bathroom to put the stuff down. And he goes, oh, God. I'm like, what is it? It is wall-to-wall mirrors in the bathroom, lady. Like 360? Like a 360 mirror view? Oh, I'm sorry, one wall had a window. One wall didn't have the mirrors.
于是我们租了这栋房子。给全家人住。我们大家凑钱，在棕榈泉租了这栋大房子。然后我们分配卧室。我和乔什最后分到了这栋房子的这间卧室。我们走进去，心想，哇，这么好的房间。然后乔什，他走进浴室去放下东西。接着他说，哦，天哪。我问，怎么了？天哪，里边是四面环镜的浴室，老天。就像360度？就像360度镜子全景？哦，不好意思，一面墙有窗户。一面墙没有镜子。
Okay. But the whole entire wall on the side of the toilet and behind it had mirrors. So like when you're sitting on the toilet, you can see yourself? Every angle. It is horrifying. Oh, my God. It is the most horrifying thing. Who would do that?
好吧。但马桶那一侧以及后面的整面墙都有镜子。所以当你坐在马桶上时，你能看到自己？各个角度。太吓人了。哦，天哪。这是最恐怖的事情。谁会干这种事？
Who would do that? I told Josh, I said, I have to turn the lights off when I go on the bathroom because this is horrible. That is seeing way too much of yourself too often. In ways you never want to see yourself. Oh my gosh. And you can't look away. It's everywhere. Where am I looking?
谁会干这种事？我告诉乔什，我说，我上洗手间时必须把灯关掉，因为这太可怕了。那是过于频繁地看到太多自己的样子。以你永远不想看到自己的方式。哦，天哪。而且你无法移开视线。到处都是。我到底在看哪？
But also it sounds like there were probably like 12 of you. Were you getting like reflection upon reflection? Yes. It's just row after row after row of you taking a crap. It's just like. This house needs to be on like Zillow Gone Wild or something. I went to see if you could still rent it because I have a friend who's turning 50 and it's no longer. Were you going to recommend it?
不过听起来当时大概有12个人吧。你们是不是能看到倒影叠着倒影？对。全都是你在一边拉屎一边一层又一层叠起来的倒影。就像是。这房子应该上那种“Zillow疯狂住宅”之类的节目。我去查了查看看还能不能租到，因为我有朋友要过50岁生日了，结果已经没有了。你本来打算推荐它吗？
I was like, well, it wasn't a nice house. Warning, the mirrors in the one bedroom, but whatever. If you go back, you need to, like, tape up, like, just bring a roll of wrapping paper and just tape up some wrapping paper over those mirrors. I mean, you got to do something. Wow. I did not know that by bringing up Esmeralda's mirrors, I was going to get that gem, but I sure I'm glad I did.
我就想，嗯，其实这房子挺好的。警告，其中一卧室的镜子有雷，不过无所谓。如果你回去，你得，比如，贴上胶带，带上一卷包装纸，直接在那些镜子上贴些包装纸。我是说，你总得做点什么。哇。我真不知道提起埃斯梅拉达的镜子会让我挖到这个宝藏，但我绝对很高兴我这么做了。
Sorry. Sorry for that visual. All right. Well, next up, we're going to come. Cut over to Nicole, who is at her desk, and she finds a box with a wooden carved bird inside. Yeah. Guess who it's from? It's from Detrick.
抱歉。为那个视觉画面道歉。好的，接下来我们要切到。切换到妮可，她正坐在办公桌前，她发现了一个盒子里装着一只木雕小鸟。对。你猜是谁送的？是迪特里克送的。
Yes. He spent hours. He watched a two-hour YouTube video, ordered special knives to make this bird for her. Yeah. And he even stained at the color of a bag she likes to use. He says it's just his way of saying, hey, what's up? Do you know what my first thought was when I saw this bird? Stanley carved a wooden bird for Phyllis. That was my first thought.
是的。他花了几个小时。他看了一个两小时的YouTube视频，订购了专门的雕刻刀来为她制作这只鸟。没错。他甚至把它的颜色上成了她喜欢用的一款包的颜色。他说这只是他表达“嘿，最近怎么样”的一种方式。你知道我看到这只鸟时的第一反应是什么吗？斯坦利给菲利斯雕刻了一只木鸟。那是我的第一反应。
I wondered, is this little nod? A little Easter egg? Was this on purpose? I texted Greg. What did he say? He said in the pilot of the paper, there was originally this whole sequence with Nicole bringing her pet bird to work. Yes.
我在想，这是一个小小的致敬吗？一个小彩蛋？这是故意的吗？我给格雷格发了信息。他说什么？他说在《办公室》试播集中，原本有这么一整段情节，是妮可带着她的宠物鸟去上班。没错。
Prop Master Scott told us about that. Yes. He said they later replaced this because they found out that the Australian version of the office had something similar with something. bringing a bird into the office. So this wooden bird carving was a callback to a former scene from the pilot. He said it still worked in this episode because they do briefly discuss her pet bird in the Two Truths and a Lie episode. So long story short, it was not intentional, but this made me realize something. What? The lost episode of the office is Pet Day. Oh. And it is also about someone bringing their bird to work. I think Greg really wants someone
道具主管斯科特跟我们说过这个。是的。他说他们后来把这个删掉了，因为他们发现澳大利亚版的《办公室》里也有类似的情节，讲的是有人带鸟去办公室。所以这个木雕小鸟是对试播集中早期场景的一个呼应。他说这集里用这个依然行得通，因为他们在“两个真话和一个谎言”那一集里确实简短讨论过她的宠物鸟。所以简而言之，这不是刻意的，但这让我意识到了一件事。什么？《办公室》失落的一集是“宠物日”。哦。而且那集也是关于有人带他们的鸟去上班。我觉得格雷格真的很想让某人
to bring a bird to work. Clearly. You know, we had an episode with a bird funeral. Yeah. What is it with Greg and birds? I hope it sees the lie today someday. I know. There's something in him that he needs to get out.
带一只鸟去上班。显然如此。你知道的，我们有一集是办鸟类的葬礼。对。格雷格到底跟鸟有什么仇？我希望有朝一日能在电视上看到那一集。我知道。他内心深处有些东西必须宣泄出来。
He has a bird story. He needs to tell. He does. So while this was not an intentional callback, we have been spotting things that are callbacks, like Oscar's gift from Michael, the clacky balls. And we got this question from Sarah L. in Ohio,
他有一个关于鸟的故事。他非讲不可。确实如此。所以虽然这不是一个刻意的呼应，但我们一直能发现一些呼应，比如奥斯卡收到迈克尔的礼物，那串响球。我们收到了来自俄亥俄州萨拉·L.的问题，
who said, it was so fun seeing all the office Easter eggs in the paper, what Easter egg would you plant as a nod to your office character or your favorite office character in the world of the paper? So I guess if we were to show up as our characters on the paper, what Easter egg would we plant? I mean, can I guess what yours is? Sure. Is it your pink mug?
她说，在《纸业公司》里看到所有《办公室》的彩蛋太有趣了，如果要在《纸业公司》的世界里种下一个彩蛋作为对你的《办公室》角色或你最喜欢的《办公室》角色的致敬，你会种下什么彩蛋？所以我想如果我们以角色的身份出现在《纸业公司》，我们会种下什么彩蛋？我是说，我能猜到你的是哪个吗？当然。是你的粉色马克杯吗？
Yeah, I would love that. I would put that pink mug back on my desk. Or maybe that crazy thing. that lucite lusite bobble thing. Yeah, that does nothing. It's just decor
对，我太喜欢那个了。我会把那个粉色马克杯放回我的桌子上。或者也许那个疯狂的。有机玻璃、有机玻璃那种晃来晃去的东西。对，什么用都没有。纯粹是装饰
that I still have. And I would also put I had this giraffe pen. It was like a blue wooden pen. I have it on my desk at home. And then it has a spring on the top where the eraser would be and then there's like a little
而且我现在还留着。我还会放我以前有的一支长颈鹿笔。那是一支蓝色的木制笔。我把它放在家里的桌子上。它的橡皮擦部位顶部有一个弹簧，然后上面还有一个小小的
yellow giraffe. It doesn't work. I think it never worked. But it was always in my cup holder. So those are the three things that I would put. on my desk? I would have the cat with the chip deer paper clip holder that was on my desk and now was on my home desk, right? I would have the little frame that when we personalized our area
黄色长颈鹿。它不能用。我觉得它从来没用过。但它一直都在我的笔筒里。所以这就是我会放的三样东西。放在我的桌子上？我会放那个带着薯片鹿造型纸夹座的猫咪，它以前在我的桌上，现在在我家里的桌上，对吧？我会放那个小相框，也就是当我们布置个人区域时
that I brought in the picture of me and my grandmother where my eyes are closed and it's in a frame that says I heart grandma. So I would have those two. And then I had a bunch of little cat figurines that lined the top of my cubicle. Yep. And also just in the midst of little cat figurine, cat figurine, all of a sudden there was a pelican. And that's a deep cut. So I think I would bring back the pelican.
我拿来的我和祖母的照片，照片里我的眼睛是闭着的，相框上面写着“我爱奶奶”。所以我会有这两样东西。然后我有一堆小猫摆件，排成一排放在我的格子间顶部。没错。而且在一堆小猫摆件、小猫摆件当中，突然出现了一只鹈鹕。那可是一个冷门梗。所以我想我会把那只鹈鹕带回来。
Well, Greg would like that. Yeah. Oh, yes, he would. Well, that was a fun question. Thanks, Sarah. Well, Nicole is now talking to mayor. They're in some type of break room. There's a shelf with a lot of baskets I want to point out.
那格雷格会喜欢的。对。哦，是的，他绝对会。好吧，那是个有趣的问题。谢谢萨拉。好吧，妮可现在正跟梅尔说话。她们在某种茶水间里。那里有个架子，上面有很多篮子，我想指出来。
Oh, did you love that? that? I love that. I counted four that I could see. One, I think, has some Cheetos in it. There's also a big green water jug. Anyway, Nicole is saying to Mir that it's too much. What Detrick's done, he went overboard. It's like freaking her out. Yeah. And then Detrick is talking to Travis, and he's noting that Nicole doesn't seem to be responding to his gift. So he's like, oh, no, did I use the wrong kind of wood? Travis is like, dude, it's not the wrong kind of wood. I mean, it's like you carved her an engagement ring. You're freaking everyone out.
哦，你喜欢那个吗？我太喜欢了。我数了数，能看到的就有四个。其中一个里面好像放了奇多（Cheetos）。还有一个大绿水壶。总之，妮可正在对梅尔说这太过分了。迪特里克做的事，他做得有点过头了。这把她吓坏了。没错。然后迪特里克正在跟特拉维斯谈话，他注意到妮可似乎对他的礼物没有什么反应。所以他在想，哦，天哪，我是不是用了错的木头？特拉维斯就说，老兄，根本不是木头的问题。我是说，你简直就像是给她雕刻了一枚订婚戒指。你把所有人都吓到了。
It was too much. Travis has, I guess this is going to be classic Travis relationship advice. He's like, just start icing her out. Like, that's what he's doing to his stepdad and it's working. Yeah. Like, ignore her. I loved the scene, but I like these two actors a lot. Me too.
这确实太过分了。特拉维斯给出了，我猜这会是标准的特拉维斯式恋爱建议。他说，直接冷落她。就像他对继父做的那样，而且很管用。对。就像，无视她。我喜欢这个场景，不过我挺喜欢这两个演员的。我也是。
Yeah. So this was one of my favorite exchanges in the episode was this. Dettrick Travis scene. I know. They're really funny together. Like if I was writing a sales call episode, I'd want the two of them to go out more. Because I loved it when they went and ran into Travis's ex-girlfriend. Exactly.
对。所以这是这集里我最喜欢的对话之一，就是这个。迪特里克和特拉维斯的这场戏。我知道。他们俩在一起太搞笑了。如果我在写一集推销电话的戏，我会想让他们俩多出去跑跑。因为我特别喜欢他们撞见特拉维斯前女友的那场戏。确实如此。
This is a good pair. Yeah. Well, listen, why don't we take a break? And when we come back, Ned is going to call so Wesley. It's going to go as well as you think. It might go worse than you think. He doesn't just call. We'll get to it.
He FaceTimes him. Yeah. So many mistakes. All right. We are back. Ned is now FaceTime. time calling so Wesley, I don't understand. Why would you FaceTime? Why? I don't know. No one does that. No. That's weird. And Ken is also there and so is as Marilda. And Ned is trying to apologize.
And Wesley's like, I don't accept your apology. Not accepted. And while they're on the phone, Ken does a fact check and notices that as Wesley claims, flammable and inflammable are the same. You can use them interchangeably. The internet begs to differ. Yeah. I was taking Ken's word for it, but that doesn't seem right. This is what I read. Flammable and inflammable neither mean the same thing nor are opposites.
Flammable refers to things that can catch on fire like wood or clothing. Inflammable refers to things that can generate fire like compressed gas. So neither of them mean not flammable. They both mean flammable. Yes. But just... In different ways. The source of their flammability is a different thing. Exactly. And because we don't know the actual sentence that Ned read, we can't say which one is appropriate.
Hmm. Okay. Well, take that so, Wesley. In your face. Or maybe not in your face. True. Depending on how he used it. Take that, Ned. We don't know. We don't know. Well, now Esmeralda is going to take the phone, and she's going to apologize for Ned. And she's going to try to sweet talk, so Wesley. And she's like, you should come work for me on TTT online. It's sexy. It has Riz. It's not suss at all.
She's like trying to, like, throw out all these useful terms. Yeah, every word that she's ever heard about, like what young people say. Yes. She's like, we have ice cream on Thursdays. And Ned is like, we all have ice cream on Thursdays. That's not an online thing. And then she does this crazy shade to Ned where she's like, you know, he's just weird around kids because he can't have kids because he's sat on. Like, what do you sit on?
She sat on something hot. A hot. And now he can't have kids. And he's like, no, I can't. He writes a little note. Holds it to camera. I can have kids. The whole thing is a hot mess.
So Wesley seems to like Esmerelda in this phone call. Yeah. He says, sure, I'd love to intern for you. And then Ken calls this a master class in talking to kids. Because he loves Esmeralda. Does he love her? Is this what's happening? Oh, is he kind of in love with her?
I think he might have a crush on her. He's certainly dazzled by her. He's dazzled. Well, So Wesley was played by Aidan Lepret. He also played the character of Max in two episodes of The Pit, which we love. And they're making a second season of, and my friend Rusty is in. and I can't wait to ask her all about how they make it. But also, according to IMDB, in addition to acting, Aiden is an award-winning singer-songwriter and music producer
who releases music under the name La Pratt. This character of So Wesley and Aiden have another thing in common. They both know what it's like to go viral. What did he go viral for? When Aiden was eight years old, he went viral on YouTube for playing the ukulele At the 2010 Hawaiian ukulele festival, he was singing Hey Soul Sister, and he got over 20 million views. Whoa! It's absolutely adorable.
Do we have it? I want to hear it. Well, that is adorable. It's so much cuteness coming at you. If you're in a bad mood one day, I highly recommend watching it because it's going to lift your spirits. Guess what I'm going to do? What? I'm going to put it in our stores.
Oh. Oh, there you go. I made the stories twice. It made the stories. I'm making the stories today. Well, technically Aiden's making the stories. Yeah, but who made you aware of Aden? Me. Yeah. Exactly. So I am a vessel for the stories. You know what? It's becoming very clear to me. What? I need a feature you more in our stories. Get ready. This did get me wondering, there's a ukulele festival? I did not know this. There is, and it is every year in Hawaii, usually in July, and it's always at Capiolani Park in Waikiki. It started back in the 1970s. And their dream, when they started it, was to present a free concert to encourage local and
international interest in the ukulele to show that it could be played as a solo instrument, not just a rhythm instrument in the background, that it can be front and center. Yeah. Well, now mayor and Oscar are going to show up at the high school. They walk into the theater. They enter the auditorium and they find Mr. Kay berating his cast. Mr. Kay is played by Michael Hitchcock, Jenna. He's just amazing. Well, he's a legend. He's a groundlings alum. He also shows up in all the Christopher guest movies. He's in everything and he always crushes it. He's just like a comedy master. He is perfection in this role. He is yelling at these kids. He's like, I have a clip. Oh, great. I was like, we have to hear him. Let's hear him. I don't know how I can sugarcoat this, so I won't.
At this point, we don't have a show. I repeat, we do not have a show. Pick that up. I see, some of you are getting emotional. Do you know what would happen if we cried at Juilliard? Do I have to remind you that Defiance High School is mounting an amazing production of Bye Bye Birdie that's going to blow your asses off? Lady, when I first moved to L.A., I joined this theater company. And the head of the theater company is total Mr. K. Vives. Except instead of the flex that he went to Juilliard, this guy had done like a single. big guest star role on a procedural. I can't even remember which one. But we were all very impressed. Yeah. He had experience in the world of television. That everyone aspired to be. He had done it.
He had done it. And everybody who was part of his theater company, there was the core theater company of people who were in all the plays that he would mount. And those were like his friends. He starred in every production. He was the star. And then there was this whole other group of people who paid dues, who never got cast in any shows, and we were all the new actors in town. And we didn't know any better. But what thing you did kit as part of paying to be in the theater company was you got free classes. Guess who taught them? He did. He taught them. He was so mean. He was so, so mean. And he would like yell at us like this. At one point, they put up this show. It was a moliere. It was a moliere show. And I got cast in it, even though I was a paying member of the company.
This was unheard of. So I'm in the cast now with him and all his friends. They needed a young person, and they were all older. So I get this part. He was so mean that throughout the course of the play, all three of the women who were playing lead roles in the play, including myself, we all quit before the show went on its feet. I hope you quit right before, like really screwed him over. Yeah. One of the ladies who had a big part, she quit, and he replaced her with his wife. Oh. And then another woman quit, and he replaced her with a man in drag. And then I quit, and I don't know who replaced me because I stopped going and I never followed up. I remember we had this rehearsal,
and I stood up for myself and another woman. As you can guess, this guy seemed to get along with men and not women. I spoke up on behalf of me and the only other woman left in the play. And he was so pissed off. He called me at home after rehearsal, and he said, don't you ever challenge me again when I am giving direction on this play? If you ever do that again, you're fired.
You can just leave the play. Do you understand me? And I thought to myself, I won't be able to go back and not challenge him again. So I said, you know what? F*** you. And fuck your play. Good. And I hung up and I never went back.
Hell yeah. And I don't know whatever happened with that play. Well, it sounds like it was going to be amazing. But when I was listening to Mr. I know, exactly. When I was listening to Mr. Kay, I was like, oh my God, he's like that guy. He's like that guy. Yeah. It's a little window into my early acting career out here in L.A.
I like that you stood your ground. Incidentally, this theater guy, he told me I would never work in this town. He literally did the old, like, classic. You'll never work a day in this town as long as I'm here, lady. Yeah. That's how he sounds in my head. Well, I did DM with Michael Hitchcock because I love him. He's so great.
And I said, we are loving Mr. K. I hope you're well. He's just a wonderful person. And I was so excited to see him in this role. Well, if I ever make the biopic of my life, I'm going to have Michael Hitchcock play this abusive theater company director man that I told off in my youth. What was his name? Well, I'll tell you his nickname. I called him Stalin.
Did it rhyme with his actual name? Please tell me it did. Okay. All right, great. It did. I started the nickname. I'm proud of it. I don't leave a snarky comment, but I will make a snarky nickname out of your actual name.
And spread it behind your back. Ha ha! Well, in this next scene, Ned is in his office and he's eating the popcorn out of the tin again. This popcorn is still going strong. It's made a comeback. Esmeralda says, come meet me in the parking lot. Oh, yeah. Something's going down.
So Ned finds Esmeralda in the parking lot. She is pacing. She is freaking out. She shows him like something on her phone. She's like, did you see what this little brat did? And then she reads what Wesley has written about her. Quote, Esmeralda Grand, 51, editor of TTT Online, begged me to work for her, quote, sexy website. Was she hoping to violate more child labor law?
And Ned's like, well, you're a lot of things, but you're not. And Esmeralda goes, 51, I know, it's slander. It's so funny. This sends her, like, on such a spiral. She's, like, more pissed that he said she was 51 than anything else. She wants to get revenge. Mm-hmm. And Ned's like, yes, but ethical revenge.
Yeah. And Esmeralda says, okay, we cut his breaks, and then what happens after is in the hand of God. Yes, he's like, no, no. So then there's going to be this scene in Ned's office where they're brainstorming how to get revenge on Wesley. Asmeralda's like, why don't we convince him his father isn't real? Why don't we give him Lyme disease? She says she thinks she has the right kind of ticks. I don't even know what that's about.
I don't even want to know. Like, why does she have ticks on the ready? Ultimately, they come up with the idea that they should send Wesley a fake press release. and if he publishes it, his reputation will be destroyed for not checking sources. Ned says, yeah, how about layoffs, potential upcoming layoffs at Corning Glass? And then Esmeralda has her fantastic classic where she compliments but gives you a dig at the same time. She goes, wow, incredible. Such a perfect level of bland.
How do you do that? And Ned's like, I don't know, it just comes naturally. She's like so natural to you. Lady, this sent me down a rabbit hole. about revenge and getting revenge and like the perfect revenge. You know, revenge is a dish best served cold. Yeah. I came across this revenge story about a musician named Dave Carroll from the band Sons of Maxwell. He was on a United Airlines flight and he observed something. Okay. Here he is being interviewed about what happened. Well, I was sitting in the back of the plane in Chicago
on a United Airlines flight, and we were waiting to deplane to catch a connecting flight to Omaha. And a woman behind me looked out the window, and she cried out, oh, my God, they're throwing guitars outside. And our bass player looked outside to see his bass guitar being thrown, and mine was thrown before that, and ultimately it was damaged. Who's throwing the guitar? The baggage handlers. Okay. So he goes on to explain that the guitar in question, his guitar was worth about $3,500, but it also had sentimental value. It was damaged. He spent about $1,200 trying to fix it, but it still doesn't sound the same. He tried to file a claim with United for damages, but nothing came of it. And he just was like, this is not cool. So he wrote a song about it. Let's hear.
Nebraska The plane departed Halifax Connecting in Chicago's Old Air passenger said From the seat behind me My God they're throwing guitars Out there The band and I exchanged a look
Best described as terror At the action on the tarmac And knowing whose projectiles These would be Show complete indifference Towards me Fix it. Your life'll just admit it.
I should have flown with some because United. United Breaks guitar. Is that the name of the song? Yes. This song went viral. Within weeks of it being released, the United Airlines stock fell by 10%. He ended up writing two more songs about it,
and they became known as the United Breaks Guitars trilogy. Oh, my gosh. Sweet revenge by Dave Carroll. And the Sons of Maxwell, you know what? I love a story also where someone turns something like that, like something that's just stuck in your craw that's irritating you into art. Make some lemonade. Yes.
So he ended up writing three hit songs about his broken guitar and probably ended up making, I don't know, I'm assuming, more money than if they had fixed the guitar. So. I hope he got some kind of like card or something from United that was like our apologies. He said in the news story that since. the song went viral that they did reach out. So that's all it took. But you know what?
Also, we've all had that with an airline. I mean, not to dogg on United or anything, but any airline, they lose your bags. Someone's indifferent. They mess up your reservation. You're stuck at the airport. You know, we've all experienced it. And there's something cathartic about this story, I think, for all of us. Like, he touched on something, which is why the song went viral.
right? Yeah, for sure. I know what song I would write. Would it be called Oceanaut? What? That's what I was going to say. I want somebody to write me a song about my Oceionot watch. Oh my gosh, you just put a call to action out there. There's some really talented people listening to Office Ladies. I bet you get a good one.
Well, maybe we should go back to the school now because Mayor and Oscar are sitting down with Mr. K and Mr. Kay does not recall Mayor at all. Oh, that pisses her off because, Clearly, she's like, I auditioned. You didn't cast me. He doesn't even remember her. And he's like, do you even work for a real paper? And she's like, yeah, we work for the truth teller. He's like, fine. If you want the truth, here's the truth. I don't remember you because you probably weren't very good. I remember the ones that were good. Yes. Exactly. Oscar has a talking head where he's doing a classic talking head. He's like, yeah, mayor has a grudge against Mr. Craig. Wait, no. No. He stops himself. He says, I will not speak up. outside of arts and leisure. Yeah. He was almost drawn back in.
Almost. We didn't touch on Kin's talking head, which I think is a classic. He has a talking head that's he's basically like, no, I'm not jealous of Ned and Asmeralta getting along so well. Really, I'm not, but he clearly is. And there's the classic reveal. It'd be like when Michael Scott was talking and then you would pull back and see Dwight. I love this.
I feel like it's a nod to how we shot the office. Ken is going on and on, and then it pulls back, and we reveal the. he's talking to Kimberly. You just see the back of her head and she goes, you know, I really need to get back to work. Yes. It was so great. The next scene up is Esmeralda and Ned. They are, you know, working on this fake press release.
And Ned notices that Esmeralda is putting tape on her face. Yeah. She's trying to give herself a tape facelift. Well, Paul Lieberstein shared with us that this tape idea was a pitch from Sabrina. Yes. How great is that? that. Paul said Sabrina asked if she could tape her skin back. She said everyone's doing it. And I guess Paul was a little skeptical, but she said she'd show him what it looked like. And then she came back
with scotch tape all over her face and hair. And Paul said she's definitely in tune to her inner clown. I have a confession. Oh, yeah. Have you done this? Oh, my God. What for? I have tape. I'm going to try it. I watched a video last night. What? Yeah. You have scotch tape right? now in your hand. I can't, you're not doing this. You watched a video on how to do it with scotch tape. There's so many. And then I found this crazy article, well, it's fascinating about Marlene Dietrich. Yes. And how she made this tape facelift famous. It was called the Crodon. If I'm saying that right, Crodon facelift. And she used surgical tape to pull her face upward and then she'd wear really high ponytails. Lady, this is how all of the ladies in Hollywood, the grand dams of Hollywood, this is what they would
Do. Lucille ball? Yes. Yes. Yes. All of them. You're doing it? Well.
But here's, I mean. You have to tuck it in your hair, though, and that is what I don't know how to do. Is that what the thing said on the- Yes. You know, it looks like is that you have tape on your face. I know. I know, because they would tuck it under a wig. Yeah.
So let me tell you, you don't. I mean, it's really nuts that you're just putting tape on your feet. Ow. I've got my hair. Let me tell you. what you need. This is what you missed by us not video engers. Yeah. Oh. It's not working. It's not working. A little bit. Well, you're holding it. Because I can't put it in my hair. You just have tape you look ridiculous. This is, you're getting more tape. Why? Well, because now I'm doing my chin. Those are my
eyes. Okay. My chin is what really needs it. Let's be honest. Let me. Hey, that worked. Oh. Oh. Okay. I can see the tape, though, from straight on, just straight on. Let's see. say you have a photo shoot. Take my picture. You could tape your chin like that, lady. For a photo shoot? Yes, because only don't turn your head, though. Okay.
If you turn profile, then I can see the tape. Okay. But if you don't, I can't. Okay, smiling. Well, don't smile. Oh, don't smile. Yeah. Oh.
It doesn't look as good when you smile. Here, see what you think. Wait, give it to me. Our desk is big. Wait. Wait, wait, I want to do two more on my. neck. Okay.
There's two more I can do on my neck. Listen, while you're taping up, let me tell you what I did. Okay. Okay. I bought the real stuff. You did? Yeah. So the real stuff has a string.
Oh my God, yes. And it's really strong tape. And it goes behind your ear or something. It goes around your head. I saw these. I saw them. This is what the old-timey Hollywood ladies would wear. And you put it like at your temples in your hair line.
Uh-huh. And then it pulls it and you have to like make it taught with the string. And it pulls it. And then you can also do it behind your ears to pull up your wrinkly neck. The waggle. So I saw an Instagram video of it. And you bought it? I fucking bought it because I buy everything that is fed to me on Instagram. It is a disease that I have.
I don't know why. But I bought it. It was while I was in Chicago doing the play because I thought, what if I put it on for like a photo shoot or for a red carpet? Did it work? No. Oh, I was... It didn't work at all.
It was stupid. It was stupid. It didn't stick. Like, I watched a whole video where you, like, part your hair so that then you, like, the string goes under your hair. I saw it. Back in the day, the ladies would wear it under their wigs. Yeah. Wigs are what really...
Okay. Okay. Here's the picture of you. It's from far away. I mean, you just... You have tape on your face, lady. I know. Me and Esmeralda.
I'm bringing us back. It's nuts. It's nuts. Now I got to... to take this shit off my face. Yes, you do. Anyway, I tried the tape thing here in front of you to don't work. We saved you all a lot of time. Don't buy it. Don't try it at home. I'm not sure who did a better job with the tape, me or Esmeralda, but we both just look like ladies with tape on our faces. Correct. So listen, now we're going to return to this Detrick Nicole storyline.
Detrick is going to play it really cool. He's going to start a conversation with Nicole, but he's going to keep it just about work, and then he's going to walk away. Yeah. She's slightly confused. She's like, oh, she wasn't expecting that. I have a time code. Oh, let's hear it. It's for this little scene. It's 20 minutes. This starts with Nicole at the coffee machine, and I saw a sticky note on the machine that
says needs more coffee. I found this confusing because there's coffee in the coffee maker, so it's not like you need to make more coffee. And sitting next to the coffee machine are three bags of coffee. So I don't think they need more coffee. However, the brand of coffee sitting next to the coffee machine is called actual coffee. That's the name of it, actual coffee. And guess what?
They're a local Ohio brand of coffee. Love it. Well done. We're in the school library now. Mayor has grabbed all the programs from the musicals. She's trying to figure out if basically Mr. Kay has been taking money in some way. Like whoever put the ad in the program, like kicked in some money and then their children are who gets the lead in the play? Yeah, I mean, she makes a pretty convincing argument. I mean, Oscar says,
I'm not sure this is definitive proof. Like, you can't make this accusation publicly, but he sort of privately says, Mayor, I think you've found something, which is that the lead in every play coincidentally, their parents took out some sort of full-page ad in the program for their local businesses. Ultimately, Mayor writes an article that does not take down Mr. Kay. She just decides against it. Her articles titled Mr. Kirby celebrates 30th year at Dary'sburg. Mr. Kay is a pillar of the community. And then she gets a phone call.
It's a tip about Mr. Kay. And then we find out that Mr. Kay apparently lied about going to Juilliard. There was more to this scene. It's really great. It's in the Peacock Extended version. It was cut from the NBC version. But Mayor goes to the source and it's a teacher at the time. the school, played by Paul Lieberstein's real-life wife, Janine Periba.
Yes! She's fantastic in this scene, and she gives us the dish on Mr. Kay. Let's hear it. Off the record? Yeah. Mr. Kay is a character. A lot of insecurity for such a tall man. Yes. Would you say he's also arrogant? I mean, some people can be both. He manages to drop Juilliard to every conversation. I went to Yale. I never bring it up. Is there anything else you can tell me about him? I just think it's all an act. Thank you.
Yes, it is all an act. That is so great. Can I use that as a quote? No, absolutely not. The last teacher who spoke poorly of Mr. Kaye got reassigned to a different school district like a bad priest in the night. Now, you want a quote? He's a pillar of the community. Hmm.
Yeah, this cuts to a mayor talking head, and she's like, he had it coming. He had it coming. And then she's like, oh, Actually, maybe I'm not that good. Maybe. She's like, no, I'm good. I'm just rusty. Well, I thought Chelsea sounded a little sick in this episode.
And when she's singing, her voice kind of cracks, guess what? What? She was sick. Chelsea told me that not only was she sick, she ended up getting Oscar sick because they worked together so much that week. I know. She said Oscar gave her grief about it in a joking way.
Well, wrapping up the storyline, Ned and Esmeralda's plot worked. He ran with the arboral. article. Wesley ran with the fake article about people getting laid off, and he got his ass handed to him. Yes. Here's the headline from the actual news that says, quote, popular child's blog spreads vicious lies. Esmeral de Grande 37, editor of TTT Online, led the investigation. We're going to end this episode. We're in the parking lot. Detrick is going to apologize to Nicole. He says, I'm sorry. I think I was a bit much. He says, you know, I like you 3.5%. Out of five. Out of five. But like casually. Like casually. Yeah. I asked Kelly Cantley, where did you shoot this? This was clearly not on the studio
lot. It was outside. She said that they used the standard oil building in downtown L.A. as the enervate exterior building. And they shot this in the Athena parking lot right across the street. Oh, that was an early call time to shoot downtown. That was some traffic, y'all. Ned is going to have this closing moment. He's back in the conference room with the students. He says, this quote, the most important part of any article is the byline. You get one reputation in this life, protect it at all costs.
The student says, who said that? He says, Geraldo Rivera. And then we go to a tag. Yeah. Travis is up on the roof. He's flying a drone. Yeah, he says, I come up here to fly my drone. It's like therapy to me. I mean, I also go to regular therapy, but this is awesome. It's just so beautiful up here. Can I bring something up? Mm-hmm. Dare I say, Greg also likes to go on roofs. Oh. Right? Birds and roofs. The Greg Daniels. He likes the roof P-O-V. He does. We went on the roof all the time. Mm-hmm. And here we are. We're back up on the roof. Well, Travis is flying his drone and he's looking at the little sort of camera lens of like what his drone is seeing.
And guess what he sees? A full-on makeout between Nicole and Detrick. Not just a little smooch. This is like smoo-smooch. Yeah. They are like at an outside table at a restaurant. A little cafe. Guess what?
It's a faky restaurant. I was wondering. Kelly Cantley said that that was an empty storefront. on a nearby corner by, you know, where they shot all of this stuff, the parking lot, they shot this little drone bit, the art department and set decoration. They just decorated the outside of an empty storefront and made it look like a restaurant, but you can't actually go inside. They're so good.
They're so good. They're so good. But yeah, cliffhanger. So here's my question. What is it? Was this just an act all day long? Are they already into each other, but they act like they're not. for the camera crew?
Oh, I didn't think of that option. That kiss was a very, not the first time you kiss someone kiss, in my opinion. I just assumed that this, like, weird freeze-out thing worked. I mean, her conversation with Mary, she seemed like legitimately kind of like, that was too much. Yeah, I agree. I just didn't know if they were trying to throw everyone off. Like, was this a Dwight Angela thing?
Yeah. Mm. to keep everyone thinking that they're not in a relationship. I just thought that kiss was a little intimate for two people who've never kissed before. Well, I guess we'll find out next week. I guess so. Well, everyone, there you have it. That is your breakdown of the paper episode four.
A big thank you to Chelsea Fry, Greg Daniels, Kelly Cantley for all your tidbits. And yes, Michael Hitchcock, thank you for responding to my DM. It was so nice just to chat with you briefly there. I guess you've learned a lot in today's episode, and I made the stories. And I'm real excited about that. You made the Insta story, lady. I did. Don't get cocky. Could go away. What? Wow. Keeping me on my toes. We love you guys. We'll see you next week. See you then. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jerkins.
Our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer, and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubicoe. Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Schultz. Our theme song is Ruppertree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.